Hallo und willkommen, also werden wir heute
ein wenig über die
Nominativ- und Akkusativ-
Personalpronomen sprechen, aber bevor wir über die Personalpronomen sprechen,
erinnern wir uns einfach daran,
was der Nominativ und der
Akkusativ eigentlich in Ordnung sind und
auch in der Vorwoche gesehen haben  der Nominativ
ist wie das Subjekt und der Akkusativ
ist wie das Objekt eines Satzes, also
schauen wir uns diesen Satz an,
Paul Mac, dann heiße Rebe, also Paul
mag den Rotwein, also ist Paul das
Subjekt des Satzes, er ist ein
Nominativ, weil er ist  macht das
Verb okay, er überfällt, er mag und
die heiße Rebe ist das Objekt des
Satzes, weil es der Empfänger
des Verbs ist, also ist es markiert wird
gemocht Sie bemerken auch nicht, dass
es Paul Mike ist, dann heiße Rebe und nicht
Paul  Mike Dead Hot Vine, warum denn, wie
wir letzte Woche entdeckt haben, ändert sich der bestimmte
Artikel, je nachdem, ob
es sich um Nominativ, Akkusativ oder Dativ handelt
, also ist in diesem Fall die Hot Vine der
Akkusativ  es ist männlich, also nimmt es
dann statt tot jetzt gilt die gleiche
Regel für die unbestimmten Artikel und
in diesem Fall wäre es zum Beispiel
Paul mag einen heißen Wein, was bedeuten würde, dass
Paul ah Rotwein mag, okay, also machen wir
weiter von dieser Nacht und  Schauen wir
uns das Positiv und die Nominativ-
Personalpronomen an und sehen, wie sie sich
ändern. Das erste, was Sie sich wohl
merken müssen, ist, dass ein Personalpronomen
ein Substantiv in einem Satz ersetzt, also
denke ich zum Beispiel an den Satz, den ein Stier Ben gefragt
hat  Ersetzen wir Ben durch ein Personalpronomen,
also wäre es whoa s und wo
ist er jetzt?
Im Deutschen ändern sich die Personalpronomen,
je nachdem, ob es sich um den Akkusativ oder
den Nominativ handelt, also ob es sich um ein Subjekt
oder ein Objekt handelt, genau wie im
Englischen, wenn Sie darüber nachdenken  es gibt
sie und sie oder er und ihn,
also ändern sich beide, sie sind beide
unterschiedlich, je nachdem, ob es sich um ein
Subjekt oder das Objekt des Satzes handelt.
Okay, beginnen wir mit der nominativen
Person  l blaue Linien und ich erinnere mich, dass
die Nominativ-Personalpronomen
das Subjekt eines Satzes ersetzen, okay, also gibt
es ein, was ist ich, es gibt, was du,
es gibt Luft, was ist, er z, sie hat es gegessen,
Veera, wir, Ära, was ein du Plural ist, so  Ich
denke, seid ihr Jungs oder wie ein Schotte
sagen würde, benutzt em und es gibt Z, was du ist
, und 0 bis Großbuchstabe, was
du in der höflichen Form ist, okay, also
schauen wir uns ein Beispiel an, in dem das Nominativ-
Personalpronomen verwendet wird, und schauen wir uns das
an  Satz
ich spiele axt Fußball Ich spiele Fußball
do kleckert Fußball ihr spielt Fußball und
Feldfußball er spielt Fußball Z
kleckert Fußball Fußball
sie spielt Fußball s kleckert Fußball X
Bitte
Villa kleckert Fußball wir spielen Fußball
und ihr kleckert Fußball ihr spielt
Fußball und Z
kleckert zishe  Pilon erster Ball tut mir leid und sie
spielen Fußball oder du spielst höflich
Fußball, also beachte, wie sich das Verb tatsächlich
je nach Thema ändert
, das passiert in jeder
einzelnen Sprache, ok  y Also lasst uns über
das Akkusativ Personalpronomen sprechen also denkt
daran, dass das Akkusativ
Personalpronomen das Objekt eines
Satzes ersetzt okay also schauen wir uns an wenn du
über mich sprichst wäre ich okay wenn
du über dich sprichst wäre es  d
wenn du über ihn sprichst
, wäre es in em wenn du
über sie sprichst, wäre es Z, also ist es nicht
anders als der Nominativ ein Personalpronomen,
wenn du über X sprichst,
wäre es s, also ist es wieder nicht anders  Wenn
Sie über uns sprechen und es ehrlich wäre,
wenn Sie über Sie sprechen
, wäre es oh, und wenn Sie
über sie oder das Höfliche für Sie sprechen,
wäre es einfach, also nicht anders als das
Nominativ-Personalpronomen  Okay, also
lass sie uns in einem Satz verwenden und so zum
Beispiel ich weiß nicht und jedes liba ich ich
liebe mich weil warum nicht
ma liebe dich ich liebe dich ich liebe in ich
liebe ihn
ich liebe sehen ich liebe sie
ich liebe s ich liebe  it and ich liebe
burns I love us and
ich liebe oil I love you guys
and if  liebe see was I love them oder
I love you ist und eine Höflichkeitsform, die
Sie wahrscheinlich nie wirklich sagen würden, okay, also
das ist ein Beispiel für die
Personalpronomen und ihren Nominativ und
Akkusativ. Ich hoffe, das hat geholfen, und ich
hoffe, dass Sie es in verwenden können  Zukunft,
also vielen Dank und auf Wiedersehen